they never demonize female sin in church
they only demonize male sin and you see
this when you see Purity speakers come
in and they allow women to come in and
blame their promiscuity on Brokenness
instead of a lack of character you know
again I would take it a lot more
seriously if they said it was a lack of
character and a lack of discernment or
anything that would take some
accountability but what they do is they
have these Chastity speakers come in and
basically blame the men for pressuring
them into sex when the truth of the
matter is women these days if they're
not these pure innocent creatures that
we make them out to be